[Music]
[Music]
Dragon Ball super is arguably the
biggest DBZ movie to date with
heart-pounding action from start to
finish whilst the movie is steeped in
the chaotic action that you've come to
expect from the franchise there's
actually a lot more going on beneath the
surface and throughout this video I'll
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about the movie and its
ending there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you don't want to know anything
about the film then I highly suggest
that you turn off now but for everyone
else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to the film picks up 41 years in
the past with para gasps and is son
Broly getting banished from Planet
Vegeta due to the latter's overwhelming
power King Vegeta worries that Brawley
has the potential to oust his son and
cannot allow this to happen so banishes
both this pride in his son of being used
as a tool that continued to have power
is reflected in para guess who two
wishes to use his son Broly as a weapon
to exact revenge this theme of family is
prevalent throughout the film with
fathers pushing their failures upon
their sons which ultimately drives them
to continue on their path plot wise the
main focus of the film is on goku and
vegeta fighting Broly as only signs are
capable of taking on other signs the
majority of the typical cast said this
fight out however that doesn't mean that
the film feels like it is lacking
anything well you first see Goku and
Vegeta they are sparring training
themselves in order to be equipped
enough in their skill set to take on
other fighters in the Dragon Ball
universe Vegeta wants to become good
enough to defend his family no matter
the cost
and again this continues the parallels
of families they are then informed that
six out of the seven dragonballs have
been stolen by freezers soldiers
freezers forces join with para gas and
Broly and form a solid unit when Viki
and Goku rush to stop freezer from
obtaining the seventh Dragon Ball they
do eventually come face to face with bro
Lee and his ilk this causes an amazing
fight that I'm sure will have many
viewers in or out of curiosity freezer
Kills para gasp and this sends Brawley
Super Saiyan Goku and Vegeta
are forced to fuse together to form go
Gaeta and this is the first time in the
entire franchise that the characters
have had to resort to this and it also
highlights that should the stakes demand
this in future the two characters can do
it in the end the characters managed to
defeat Broly but decide to form a pact
with him instead of killing him goku
makes a contract with Broly and finally
accepts his sign heritage a name stating
that he wants to be friends overall it's
in awesome finale for the film that
showcases that allies are stronger and
that we should not cast out those who
could be won out of fear the same fear
which forces the fathers to make their
children weapons it's a really
interesting take and one of the most
mature aspects that I've seen in any
Dragon Ball related media I had a blast
with the film and think that a lot of
fans will too obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the film and what you
took from its ending make sure you
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of this
week's are the big release glass which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are addicted to
anime so if that's the kind of thing you
like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best not see
you next time take care peace
[Music]